Undoubtedly one of modern history’s most
notorious and abhorrent killers -- his crimes
are the stuff of nightmares.
Over the course of 13 years, he prowled for
men and lured them back to his house before
drugging and strangling them.
In all he took the lives of 17 men between
1978 and 1991.
But simply killing his victims wasn’t enough
for Jeffrey Dahmer.
He never wanted them to leave him so he saved
“trophies” — including severed heads.
Eventually, he ate parts of his victims.
Dahmer was captured in 1991 and sentenced
to 16 life terms.
He was killed by fellow prison inmate Christopher
Scarver in 1994.
Today let’s take a look back on the serial
killer’s life.
Early Life
Jeffrey Dahmer was born on May 21, 1960 in
Milwaukee, Wisconsin to Lionel and Joyce Dahmer.
He was described by his mother as a beautiful
baby, and both parents considered him to be
a normal child.
His teachers saw him differently.
At least one — his first grade teacher -- wondered
if Jeffrey was neglected at home and noted
he was a reserved child on his report card.
It’s true, both of Jeffrey’s parents didn’t
spend a lot of time with him.
When Jeffrey was young, his father was in
college earning his chemistry degree and Jeffrey’s
mother was often bedridden recovering from
illnesses.
Jeffrey’s parents had a tumultuous marriage
that he later described as “extreme tension”
from the constant arguing at home.
Yet, there was no doubt Lionel and Joyce Dahmer
loved their son and tried to do the best for
him.
When he was six years old, worried Jeffrey
might not take well to a new baby brother,
they let him pick out his name.
Jeffrey named his younger brother David.
The Dahmer family moved a few times before
eventually settling in Bath, Ohio in 1968.
If there were any red flags that indicated
future violence in the young Jeffrey, it was
his fascination with animal bones and how
they “fit together.”
The interest in carcasses began when he was
four years old.
One day, Jeffrey was helping his father clear
animal remains from under the house and Jeffrey
was “oddly thrilled” by the sound of the
bones dropping into the metal bucket.
He later started collecting them; searching
in ditches and along streets for roadkill.
He began dismembering the bodies behind the
house in a patch of wooded area and stored
the various body parts in jars in the family’s
woodshed.
On one occasion, Jeffrey decapitated the corpse
of a dog before nailing the body to a tree.
When he was ten years old, over dinner, Jeffrey
asked his father what would happen if chicken
bones were placed in bleach.
Lionel, a chemist, interpreted his son’s
question as mere scientific curiosity and
he took the opportunity to teach his son about
the proper way to clean and preserve his collections.
Jeffrey later admitted at the age of 14 he
began experiencing sexual “compulsions.”
He desired boys, not girls, and the sexual
fantasies involved submission, violence, and
death.
He began drinking as a teenager to suppress
his urges and didn’t talk to anyone about
the disturbing thoughts he was having.
At the age of 16, he fantasized about raping
a jogger he saw regularly and planned to attack
the man.
One day Jeffrey lay in wait with a baseball
bat in the bushes along the man’s regular
route.
The man didn’t come by that day, and Jeffrey
never attempted to carry it out again.
At Revere High School, most of his classmates
thought of Dahmer as an outcast with a few
friends; some were troubled by his heavy drinking.
He drank both beer and liquor while at school
by smuggling it inside the lining of his army
fatigue jacket.
His grades were average and then took a dive
as his drinking spun out of control in 1977.
He played clarinet briefly in band, and was
a decent tennis player.
Overall, his teachers observed Jeffrey as
polite and quiet.
Although he was awkward, he regularly amused
his classmates by staging pranks such as acting
out seizures, knocking over items, and making
loud, obnoxious noises.
The pranks were so popular, similar behavior
was referred to as “doing a Dahmer.”
By the end of his high school, Dahmer’s
parents’ troubled marriage finally came
to an end after an unsuccessful attempt at
counseling.
In early 1978, Lionel moved out of the house.
Dahmer graduated in May the same year.
A few weeks after graduation, Dahmer committed
his first murder when he picked up a hitchhiker.
Eighteen-year-old Steven Mark Hicks was on
his way to a rock concert when Dahmer lured
him back to his house to hang out and drink
a few beers before the show.
By now, Dahmer lived alone at his parents’
house -- his mother had moved out with younger
brother David while his father took up residence
at a local motel.
Hicks and Dahmer spent a few hours together
listening to music and drinking.
When Hicks was ready to leave, Dahmer didn’t
want him too, so he struck him in the head
with a 10 lb.
dumbbell and strangled him to death while
Hicks was unconscious.
He then masturbated over his body, moved him
to the crawl space under the house and dissected
his body before burying it in a shallow grave.
Several weeks later, Dahmer unearthed Hicks’
body, pared the flesh from the bones and dissolved
it in acid.
He crushed Hicks’ bones with a sledgehammer
and scattered them all in the woodlot behind
the house.
A short time later, Dahmer’s father visited
his son and learned he was living alone.
He moved back in the house and convinced Dahmer
to enroll in college.
Dahmer spent three months at Ohio State University
before dropping out.
In early 1979, at the urging of his father,
he joined the U.S. Army.
Dahmer served as a combat medic in Germany
but his performance deteriorated due to his
drinking.
He was honorably discharged in March of 1981.
At least two soldiers later attested Dahmer
raped them while in the service — one repeatedly
over the course of 17 months and the other
once after Dahmer drugged him.
Killing Spree
“The only motive that there ever was was
to completely control a person; a person I
found physically attractive.
And keep them with me as long as possible,
even if it meant just keeping a part of them.”
Following his discharge, Dahmer returned home
to Ohio but stayed only a brief time.
He was arrested for disorderly conduct which
prompted his father to arrange for Dahmer
to live with his grandmother in Wisconsin.
His alcoholism continued and he was arrested
for indecent exposure.
He was arrested again in 1986 when two boys
accused him of masturbating in front of them.
In September of 1987, Dahmer took his second
victim, Steven Tuomi.
According to Dahmer, he has no memory of killing
Tuomi -- they had checked into a hotel room
together and drank heavily...when Dahmer woke
in the morning he discovered Tuomi’s dead
body, with blood on his hands.
Dahmer bought a large suitcase to transport
Tuomi's remains to his grandmother's basement,
where he dismembered and masturbated on the
corpse before disposing of the remains.
Only after Dahmer killed another two victims
at his grandmother’s home did she tire of
her grandson's late nights and drunkenness
— although she had no knowledge of his other
activities — and she forced him to move
out of the premises in 1988.
That September 1989, Dahmer had an extremely
lucky escape: An encounter with a 13-year-old
Laotian boy resulted in charges of sexual
exploitation and second-degree sexual assault
for Dahmer.
He pleaded guilty, claiming that the boy had
appeared much older.
While awaiting sentencing for his sexual assault
case, Dahmer again put his grandmother's basement
to gruesome use: In March 1989, he lured,
drugged, strangled, sodomized, photographed,
dismembered and disposed of Anthony Sears,
an aspiring model.
At his trial for child molestation in May
1989, Dahmer was the model of contrition,
arguing eloquently, in his own defense, about
how he had seen the error of his ways, and
that his arrest marked a turning point in
his life.
His defense counsel argued that he needed
treatment, not incarceration, and the judge
agreed, handing down a one-year prison sentence
on "day release" — allowing Dahmer to work
at his job during the day and return to the
prison at night — as well as a five-year
probationary sentence.
Years later, in an interview with CNN, Lionel
Dahmer stated that he wrote a letter to the
court that issued the sentence, requesting
psychological help before his son's parole.
However, Jeffrey Dahmer was granted an early
release by the judge, after serving only 10
months of his sentence.
He briefly lived with his grandmother following
his release, during which time he does not
appear to have added to his body count, before
moving back into his own apartment.
Over the following two years, Dahmer's victim
count accelerated, bringing his total from
four to 17.
He developed rituals as he progressed, experimenting
with chemical means of disposal and often
consuming the flesh of his victims.
Dahmer also attempted crude lobotomies, drilling
into victims' skulls while they were still
alive and injecting them with muriatic acid.
He was careful to select victims on the fringes
of society, who were often itinerant or borderline
criminal, making their disappearances less
noticeable and reducing the likelihood of
his capture.
As the murders piled up, Dahmer was still
unsatisfied, he said later:
“I was completely swept along with my own
compulsion.
I don't know how else to put it.
It didn't satisfy me completely, so maybe
I was thinking, 'Maybe another one will.
Maybe this one will.'
And the numbers started growing and growing
and just got out of control, as you can see.”
On May 27, 1991, Dahmer's neighbor Sandra
Smith called the police to report that an
Asian boy was running naked in the street.
When the police arrived, the boy was incoherent,
and they accepted the word of Dahmer — a
white man in a largely poor African-American
community — that the boy was his 19-year-old
lover.
In fact, the boy was 14 years old and a brother
of the Laotian teen Dahmer had molested three
years earlier.
The police escorted Dahmer and the boy home
and, clearly not wishing to become embroiled
in a homosexual domestic disturbance, took
only a cursory look around before leaving.
Once the police left the scene, Dahmer killed
the boy and proceeded with his usual rituals.
Had they conducted even a basic search, police
officers would have found the body of Dahmer's
12th victim, Tony Hughes.
Before he was finally arrested, on July 22,
1991, he killed four more men.
The Crime Scene
Dahmer's killing spree ended when he was arrested
on July 22, 1991.
That day, two Milwaukee police officers picked
up Tracy Edwards, a 32-year-old African American
man who was wandering the streets with a handcuff
dangling from his wrist.
They decided to investigate the man's claims
that a "weird dude" had drugged and restrained
him.
They arrived at Dahmer's apartment, where
he calmly offered to get the keys for the
handcuffs.
Edwards claimed that the knife Dahmer had
threatened him with was in the bedroom.
When the officer went in to corroborate the
story, he noticed Polaroid photographs of
dismembered bodies lying around.
Dahmer was subdued by the officers.
Subsequent searches revealed a head in the
refrigerator, three more in the freezer and
a catalog of other horrors, including preserved
skulls, jars containing genitalia and an extensive
gallery of macabre Polaroid photographs of
his victims.
Dahmer’s refrigerator and Polaroid photographs
became inextricably associated with his notorious
killing spree.
In 1996, following Dahmer’s death, a group
of Milwaukee businessmen raised more than
$400,000 to purchase the items he used for
his victims — including blades, saws, handcuffs
and a refrigerator to store body parts.
They promptly destroyed them in an effort
to distance the city from the horrors of Dahmer's
actions and the ensuing media circus surrounding
his trial.
Trial and Imprisonment
Jeffrey Dahmer’s trial began in January
1992.
Given that the majority of Dahmer's victims
were African American, there were considerable
racial tensions and so strict security precautions
were taken, including an eight-foot barrier
of bulletproof glass that separated him from
the gallery.
The inclusion of only one African American
on the jury provoked further unrest, but was
ultimately contained and short lived.
Lionel Dahmer and his second wife attended
the trial throughout.
Dahmer initially pleaded not guilty to all
charges, despite having confessed to the killings
during police interrogation, but he eventually
changed his plea to guilty by virtue of insanity.
His defense then offered the gruesome details
of his behavior, as proof that only someone
insane could commit such terrible acts.
Dahmer later said in an interview, “It's
hard for me to believe that a human being
could have done what I've done, but I know
that I did it.”
The jury chose to believe the prosecution's
assertion that Dahmer was fully aware that
his acts were evil and chose to commit them
anyway.
On February 15, 1992, they returned after
approximately 10 hours' deliberation to find
him guilty, but sane, on all counts.
He was sentenced to 15 consecutive life terms
in prison, with a 16th term tacked on in May.
“It is now over.
This has never been a case of trying to get
free.
I didn't ever want freedom.
Frankly, I wanted death for myself.
This was a case to tell the world that I did
what I did, but not for reasons of hate.
I hated no one.
I knew I was sick or evil or both.
Now I believe I was sick.
The doctors have told me about my sickness,
and now I have some peace.
I know how much harm I have caused...
Thank God there will be no more harm that
I can do.
I believe that only the Lord Jesus Christ
can save me from my sins...
I ask for no consideration.”
Dahmer reportedly adjusted well to prison
life, although he was initially kept apart
from the general population.
He eventually convinced authorities to allow
him to integrate more fully with other inmates.
He found religion in the form of books and
photos sent to him by his father, and he was
granted permission by the Columbia Correctional
Institution to be baptized by a local pastor.
Final Days
On November 28, 1994, in accordance with his
inclusion in regular work details, Dahmer
was assigned to work with two other convicted
murderers, Jesse Anderson and Christopher
Scarver.
After they had been left alone to complete
their tasks, guards returned to find that
Scarver had brutally beaten both men with
a metal bar from the prison weight room.
Dahmer was pronounced dead after approximately
one hour.
Anderson succumbed to his injuries days later.
In 2015, Christopher Scarver spoke to the
New York Post about his reasons for killing
Dahmer.
Scarver alleged that he was disturbed not
only by Dahmer's crimes, but by a habit Dahmer
had developed of fashioning severed limbs
from prison food to antagonize other inmates.
After being taunted by Dahmer and Anderson
during their work detail, Scarver said that
he confronted Dahmer about his crimes before
beating the two men to death.
He also claimed that prison guards allowed
the murders to happen by
In Dahmer's will, he had requested upon his
death that his body be cremated as soon as
possible, but some medical researchers wanted
his brain preserved so it could be studied.
Lionel Dahmer wanted to respect his son's
wishes and cremate all remains of his son.
His mother felt his brain should go to research.
The two parents went to court and a judge
sided with Lionel.
After over a year Dahmer's body was released
from being held as evidence and the remains
were cremated as he had requested.
In August 2012, nearly two decades after his
death, it was reported his childhood home
in Bath, Ohio — where he committed his first
murder in 1978, and buried his victim's remains
— was on the market.
Its owner, musician Chris Butler, stated that
the property would make a great home, as long
as the buyer could "get past the horror factor."
In March 2016, Butler put the house up for
rent for $8,000 for the week of the Republican
National Convention.
As of July 2017, the house was no longer listed
on the market, according
to Zillow.com.